the developing news a woman accused in
the death of a tow truck driver last
month appeared in court this morning
nhp says colette to spain was the driver
who slammed into ryan billet it was on
the side of the 215.
she is now charged with leaving the
scene of a deadly crash which is a
felony
bianca holmen was in court this morning
and has more on the latest developments
hi bianca
this afternoon so this was a preliminary
hearing to see if the case goes forward
the prosecution called five witnesses
the first was an nhp administrative
assistant
who took the report from colette to
spain the day after
the crash so this is some previous
file footage and so the 51 year old
filled out a report saying she was
involved in a crash the night before
lisa carter testified that de spain
filled out the report herself
the defense focused on how cooperative
de spain was including sharing pictures
of her van
carter also said that despain did not
ask many questions which is not
common oftentimes she said people ask
many questions about the process once
the form is turned in
the second witness was an hp trooper who
responded to the crash scene
and he was also there when de spain was
questioned the next day
now this is an ongoing case and we will
definitely continue to keep you updated
as
things develop online and on air bianca
holmen
8 news now